cbs news senior national security
contributor michael morell served as
both acting and deputy director of the
cia under president obama and he was
also president george w bush's
intelligence briefer mike good morning
to you we just heard a bit from roxanna
about how bad the situation there is in
afghanistan what i'm curious to know is
why is this happening so quickly
so tony
the afghan forces
needed the u.s military
to be capable um even marginally capable
of fighting the taliban so when the u.s
military left the capability of those
forces declined significantly that's one
reason the other reason is
the will to fight
declined just just eroded overnight in
april when we announced that we were
leaving so literally thousands of afghan
forces are abandoning their posts some
of them are going home some of them are
joining the taliban because they can
read the writing on the wall
and what are your concerns in the short
term about the situation there
yeah so so tony in the short term
there's a couple concerns
one is for the safety of the americans
there
they are at risk from the taliban
the taliban sees the u.s military
force that remains in the country to
protect the embassy and the additional
force that's coming in
to help with the evacuation
they see those forces as
as invaders so they are likely to try to
attack them so i would expect attempted
suicide attacks against u.s
personnel in afghanistan
and and i would also
worry about what we call green on blue
attacks these are attacks by afghan
security forces on americans so there
are many afghan security forces that are
immensely angry at what the u.s has done
here and they could take out their
weapon and shoot the americans that
they're working with so there's a couple
deep concerns here in the short term
about the safety of americans so
shifting to the longer term mike we went
into afghanistan in the first place to
deny al qaeda a staging ground for
further attacks on the u.s after 9 11.
in the medium to longer term is it a
concern of yours that they could come
back in and set up operations
tony there is no doubt at what's going
to happen here um the taliban is going
to take over the government probably in
a matter of weeks
they will allow despite what they say
they will allow al qaeda back into the
country and al qaeda will start to
rebuild and not only will al qaeda
that is currently in afghanistan or in
pakistan be there but the al-qaeda guys
who have been in iran for a long time
will join them in afghanistan and i
expect extremists from around the world
will want to go to afghanistan now in
sort of a celebration of the defeat of
the united states so i think the
capability of the terrorists in
afghanistan is going to
increase rapidly over the next several
months knowing all of that then mike
should president biden reconsider this
full withdrawal
so i don't think so dana um there is no
way we're going to win this war we've
been fighting it for 20 years
we could fight it for another 20 years
and the taliban will still be waiting us
out um so what i have what i think we
have to do going forward is we have to
figure out a way to collect intelligence
without an embassy to collect
intelligence on what al qaeda is doing
in afghanistan to monitor their plans
their their capabilities and we have to
figure out how the u.s military if those
capabilities
rebuild to the point of a threat to the
homeland how we're going to use the
military to degrade those capabilities
and not allow them to attack us again
mike it's vlad uh those of us of a
certain age have that searing image of
the evacuation of the us embassy in
saigon back in 1975. what's less talked
about is the humanitarian crisis that
followed something that is going to
happen in afghanistan right now so what
can we do about that
so vlad there's there's there's two
issues here one is is is afghan citizens
who will flee the country
in fear of the taliban
and they're going to go to
largely pakistan which is not the most
stable country on the planet so that's
going to put pakistani stability at risk
and they're going to go to central asia
the other factor here in terms of
humanitarian
in terms of humanitarian issues is what
happens to those tens of thousands
probably a hundred thousand
afghans who worked for the united states
the last 20 years for state department
for the defense department and for cia
those people will be under threat and uh
we have to work as hard as we can to get
them out of the country mike we're
running out of time but we spent 20
years hundreds of billions of dollars
and 2 000 or more american lives on the
ground there in afghanistan and we're
essentially back where we were in 2001.
should we have gotten out way earlier
tony that's what i believe um i believe
that we should have left
in early
20
early 2002
when we had either killed captured or
driven from afghanistan al qaeda
and we should have left and we should
have told the taliban if you ever let al
qaeda back into the country we will be
back
um we should never have made the
decision that we are going to try to
change
afghanistan into a liberal democracy
that was simply not possible we should
have never tried
and of course now we're facing a similar
situation one that we faced in the past
as a country uh michael morell thank you
as always for your insight and analysis
we appreciate it